but you come and tell them is that I play
amputee soccer or football on crutches
if they do not know the discipline they do not know
then they do it and it is illogical
impossible until they get to see it and
they see us play
I wanted it
already after my accident then stop
play our time until you just have
two years three years that have three of
amputee soccer
and participate or live with people
within our same conditions of
help help
accept your condition is to value your
team to our teammates because
We are 14 people who each have their
situation situation of losing his leg and
how do you realize or coexisting with
you were born
in our new conditions we are
they forget because we are all the same here
i